as he notified the world that the leader
of ISIL was dead u.s. president Trump
championed his own achievements by
making the death of Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
son more significant than that of Osama
bin Laden this is the biggest there is
this is the worst ever Osama bin Laden
was very big but Osama bin Laden became
big with the World Trade Center
fact-checkers called out some of his
comparisons The Associated Press saying
a number of Trump's statements were
simply not true nobody ever heard of
Osama bin Laden until really the World
Trade Center when in fact the Central
Intelligence Agency operated a dedicated
unit to tracking bin Laden which went
back to the mid 1990s and he'd been on
the FBI most wanted list for years Trump
went on to say about a year you'll have
to check it a year year and a half
before the World Trade Center kindred
the book came out I was talking about
Osama bin Laden I said you have to kill
him you have to take him out nobody
listen to me and to this day I get
people coming up to me they said you
know what one of the most amazing things
I've ever seen about you is that you
predicted that Osama bin Laden had to be
killed before he knocked down the World
Trade Center it's true in one of his
books released in 2000 Trump mentions
Osama bin Laden once as one of many
threats to u.s. national security but
didn't say he should have been killed on
the US invasion of Iraq Trump said I had
absolutely nothing to do with going into
Iraq and I was totally against it but
there's no evidence he said that
publicly and the year before the
invasion are you for inviting Iraq yeah
I guess so
you know I wish it was I wish the first
time it was done correctly while in
office Trump has made a lot of false or
misleading claims according to the
Washington Post he's made more than
13,000 of them since he took office
almost three years ago
Anders Chapelle al Jazeera James Warren
is the executive editor of news guard an
organization that writes credibility of
news and information websites it was
also the Washington DC bureau chief for
the Chicago Tribune and joins us by
Skype from Chicago good to have you with
us
you're not entirely surprised by some of
the fact-checking issues going on with
Sunday speech by the US president but it
did get a lot of attention that would
have otherwise been paid to impeachment
in a sense as he won it's not what he
wanted for sure to that extent he's he's
a master at deflection and taking
control of the news cycles it's one
particular reason why the traditional
daily news briefing by a spokesman is
now a thing of the past people all
around the world your viewers will often
see him with maybe a helicopter whirring
in the background whirring in the
background outside the White House
taking questions
forever and ever he can decide which
ones he supposedly hears and which ones
he doesn't and he's an absolute you know
a quote machine I think he's given about
202 or so interviews up to this point is
presidency which Dwarfs that of his
predecessors including President Obama a
good percentage of those no surprises
gone to the Fox News Network around 66
to one last week and at this very moment
as we're speaking he's speaking to the
nation's of police chiefs not too far
away from where I'm sitting here in
Chicago and has come in blasting in
classically petulant puerile hyperbolic
fashion bashing the city of Chicago for
its high homicide rate and getting
particularly personal and Las newsworthy
as he has attacked the Superintendent of
Police in Chicago who's decided not to
attend this function this morning you
know there are a lot of organizations
which have spent years taking apart the
claims the truthfulness the facts of
what the US president says but does any
of that really hurt his credibility and
standing with voters especially his core
base well that's a portent qualifiers
core base if it's a round 35 40 percent
it would seem to this point not but you
can't win a presidential election next
November 35 or 40 percent so it's going
to be absolutely fascinating to see how
many of the independents and critic
a lot of suburban college educated white
females who were pretty supportive of
him when he ran for president against
Hillary Clinton not so last year when
they had to vote for their new Congress
people in some cases a good many cases
switching from the Republican side to
the Democratic it'll be really
interesting when we talk say about a
year from now what they feel about this
this daily litany of misstatements
outright lies deflections 13000 as you
just said chronicled by The Washington
Post 13,000 yeah it is a bold new era in
politics at least I think we can say
James warrant there thank you so much it